we're asked to find the area of the
shaded region so the area of this red
shaded region so this is interesting
this is almost a 10 by 10 square except
we have these quarter circles that are
cut out so the area of this would be the
area of what a 10 by 10 square would be
minus the area of these quarter circles
and each of these quarter circles it's a
quarter of a circle with a radius 3 I
think we can assume that all of these if
you took the distance from here to the
outside of this quarter circle and have
radius 3 so if you put four quarter
circles together you're going to have a
complete white circle so one way to
think about this is that the area of
this whole red region is going to be the
area of the entire square which is 10 by
10 so it's going to be 10 times 10 which
is 100 whatever square units we have and
then we're going to subtract out the
we're going to subtract out the area of
the four quarter circles and that area
is going to be equivalent to one Cirque
the area of one circle with a radius of
three so what's the area of a circle
with radius three well the formula for
area of a circle is PI R squared or R
squared pi so the radius is three so
it's going to be 3 times 3 which is 9
times pi 9 pi so we have a hundred minus
nine pi is the area of the shaded region
and we got it right